[Music]
[Music]
I'd like now to introduce to you
professor Stephen Hawking in your
handouts you'll find a very elaborate
introduction and you will find very
interesting elements in it as a
distinguished educator researcher and
public communicator Stephen Hawking has
had a transforming effect in his area
and indeed in all of science we are
deeply appreciative of his commitment to
be with us and to share his views of the
importance of applying technology to
disabled persons professor Stephen
Hawking
[Applause]
can you hear me
technology has transformed the outlook
firms are disabled people like me can
now move around independently and they
can communicate the fact that you are
listening to me now shows what
technology can do even if it does give
me a Scandinavian or American accent the
main problem of communicating for people
like me we can't speech that's what is
called the baud rate that is the rate at
which information can be conveyed normal
speed is between 120 and 180 words a
minute
by contrast a reasonable typist can do
40 to 60 words a minute lost if one were
to equip normal people with keyboards
they could communicate between half and
a quarter of the speech rate however
many people who can't speech also have
not your disabilities like me and can
use a keyboard instead they have to use
one or more switches operated by head or
hand movement this is where the
information flow problem really
confronts one one might be able to
operate a slip two or three times a
second this would mean that one could
send information at a rate of 2 or 3
bits a second one bit of information is
the answer to a yes/no question
by contrast if you take an average were
to be about Heil characters you assume
that any character can follow any other
character normal speech has an
information flow rate of between 50 and
75 bits a second however the real
information flow in human speech is much
less than this in the case of political
speeches that is practically zero this
is because spelling out a sentence
letter by letter is inefficient most
sequences of letters don't make
recognizable words let alone meaningful
sentences so there's a lot of redundancy
in specifying every letter that is much
more efficient a tip works or in whole
fridges from a list of likely ones and
the occasional cases had the words or
phrases don't appear on the list one can
always resort to spelling them out
letter by letter to translate the
presence of a switch into letters words
for sentences requires computers the
development of microprocessors in the
last 15 years has meant that virtually
unlimited computing power thus available
at a reasonable cost what one needs a
sufficient software to translate the
input from the switch into sentences I
can manage about
fifteen words a minute with the
equalizer program that I use that is not
too bad since an information flow rate
of three bits a second corresponds that
when defiled to 13 words a minute but
obviously their scope for improvement
having decoded the signals from some
input device such as a switch London has
a broadcasted in the form people can
understand this could mean visually with
text or diagrams on the screen but if
you want to communicate like colors
which is what people in my position
would like you need a speech
computerised speech synthesizers have
improved a great deal in recent years
and this is important not only does one
want to be understood but also one
doesn't want to sound like Mickey Mouse
or italic this voice of mine may be a
bit tinny in Irish but it is almost
human
there are other ways in which technology
can assist a disabled for instance I
have been Freret and radio environment
control with which I can open doors turn
on lights and operate a television I
also have a mobile phone that I can use
to call for help if one is unfortunate
enough to be disabled this is the agent
which took me so I probably wouldn't
have survived and I certainly wouldn't
have been able to write a best-selling
book if I had been born any earlier the
disabled had a lot to hang technology
for that is all I had to say for the
moment thank you for listening
you